you talk about the 3DS of networking do
you know what yeah there's a while ago
since I've done that in that book yeah
we don't the we talk about sort of
distance uh donating and a diversity um
so I think the the reason these are
important uh so distance is some of your
relationships are going to be very close
to you so um my business partner she's
she's super super close to me super
important in in my in my kind of uh my
network um she's very close to my
context but sometimes there are people
that are further away from where you are
that can have a different perspective
and can have um you know see things that
you can't see in your world so kind of
distance is quite important when you're
looking at people you don't basically
want your network to be made up of
people you see every day like we want so
kind of some difference there um
donating so we want to make sure that we
are giving because then we will kind of
get lots back um and then we want lots
of difference so you don't want an echo
chamber of people just like you um and
when we're looking at sort of difference
and diversity there are four rol roles
that we recommend people to build into
their Network so and I think everyone
should have these I don't think
everyone's got them but I think everyone
everyone should have them so the first
role would be a mentor so somebody and
this this gets really over complicated I
just think a mentor is somebody who has
done what you would like to do that you
could have one meeting like you could be
My Mentor because you've done something
I want to do we've had one meeting and
we might we might not meet again but you
still mentored me it doesn't have to be
this relationship that endures for the
rest of yours and my career so it's just
someone who's done what you want to do
and they you advice easy um second one
is a peer so a peer is someone who is
going through what you are going through
um really helpful to accelerate your
development because I can talk to you
about what I'm doing and you're doing it
too and you get it and we can help each
other like Sarah Ellis has been my peer
for 20 years I happens now to work with
her but my I would not be where I am if
it wasn't for her she's accelerated my
growth massively um the next one is a
sponsor so a sponsor is someone who can
advocate for you so they have got access
and influence over an area you're
interested in so you've got to just
think well what am I interested in am I
interested in writing a book am I
interested in starting a podcast am I
interested in that position and that
team over there like who's got access
and influence that person is it could be
a brilliant sponsor for you um you can't
ask for sponsorship so I can't just say
can you say BR brilliant things about me
and that team over there that sponsor
needs to see me at my best so when we
talked about strengths we want that
person to see our strengths like really
see us in action they're much more like
to sports then and then the fourth role
as a coach now uh this doesn't have to
be a professional coach they are quite
expensive to have a career coach not
definitely not accessible to everybody I
think it's better to think of this as
someone who's got a coaching approach
which means they're very good at asking
questions right and and they're very
good at just stopping talking to let you
think they might follow with another
question but what they are not doing is
answering the question that's for you to
do and so if you know people who've got
that ability they're really really
helpful to have in your career Community
because they'll help you think
differently and so as well as like the
3DS I actually think those four roles
again you know I said that we are
revolving our thinking all the time we
wrote the book well the book was
published in 2020 and since then we've
trained like almost 200,000 people and
in it was almost like in each one of the
conversations I have I get some feedback
on how effective tools are and they're
they're kind of we're always evolving
them we're always seeing what sticks
we're always seeing what's useful and I
think I'm finding that those four roles
and people really focusing on those are
what one of the most useful ways they
can build their Community the principal
people helping people but the Practical
focusing on those four roles hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye